could you envision a trade for that game
breaking type of a talent there's been a
lot of chatter about aj green i don't
know that stefan diggs would quite fall
into that category where he would
command double coverage and open up the
rest of the offense but do you think
bill belichick has something that is
percolating here where he's going to get
tom brady his help because we see it all
the time you know bill belichick when
you least expect to expect it and he'll
pull some sort of a deal and he's
probably working on some deal we're not
thinking about involving a defensive
player or something like that but do you
think that it it makes sense for them to
make a run at a receiver
who can come in and and give tom brady
that thing he needs that element that
draws attention and opens up the rest of
the offense no i don't think they would
do it for a receiver because i think it
would take a little bit too much time to
bring someone up to speed but i do think
trent williams is still on the table
there the redskins i don't know what the
redskins are doing why are they not
trading guys that can get them picks
back and start the actual rebuild it's
absolutely insane ryan carroll the
answer you know i know the answer but
ryan kerrigan should be traded tren
williams should be traded they should be
trading these guys who can get them
picks back and start a real rebuild in
washington so that would be a guy i
would see i could potentially see going
to the patriots just because their
offensive line has been a weakness and
you know you want to run the ball and
guess what if you can't have an
explosive weapon for tom brady you know
what makes tom brady special as well
time and if he has time it doesn't
matter who's on the field it doesn't
matter if you have a burner i could be
on the field playing slot receiver and
i'd get open if tom brady has time so i
just had i just didn't i just visualized
that one no that was very good time time
is time if tom brady has time he will
carve anyone up in the entire nfl so i
could see something like that happening
as opposed to getting a receiver
i'm just picturing you running and
counting your steps before you cut left
or right one two three four five hey
i've lost some weight maybe maybe say a
nice compliment to your friend once in a
while maybe some positive you know
reinforcements you look good you look
good oh that good thanks mike i had to
draw it out of you hey hey let me let me
let me say this i got i got a name for
you to ponder emmanuel sanders not not
that he's going to be
a game breaker but they tried to sign
him to an offer sheet several years ago
remember when he was restricted free
agent in pittsburgh they signed an offer
sheet the steelers matched it and when
he became a free agent he ended up in
denver instead and i think that the
broncos are teetering dangerously close
to fire sale territory but emmanuel
sanders may be a guy that that they want
to look into because you can get him for
a lot less than an aj green i don't know
if the broncos broncos would fire sale
though because
do you really think john elway would
just start gutting that roster john
elway feels like a guy who's gonna just
go down to the bitter end saying hey if
i have my six seven quarterback and a
defense that was good five years ago
will be good that's that seems like the
vibe in denver i also think if denver
wins this game against the titans on
sunday and i have famously said that if
the titans are underdogs you got to go
you got to bet on them and if they're
favorites fade them but if the broncos
win this game on sunday
john ellis gonna start selling himself
two and four we've lost a lot of close
games we're still in this thing we have
some division games coming up if we can
win those it will be it will be a
different story
i want to make one last point before we
take our break and this is something
that i think gets overlooked as it
relates to the greatness of bill
belichick one thing that he has mastered
over time and i think the critical mass
came after the loss to kansas city on
that monday night five years ago and it
was the on to cincinnati on to
cincinnati routine in the post game
press conference he unlike any other
coach in any other sport has mastered
the ability to get his players to forget
what happened yesterday forget about it
whether it's we won the super bowl
whether it's we lost the super bowl
whether it's we won by 30 whether it's
we lost by 30 whether it's we lost on a
bad call or we lost on a lucky bounce or
we won on a lucky bounce they have
complete and total amnesia they carry
none of that baggage into the next game
into the next season into the next month
and no one else can do that the patriots
can and he has figured that out i don't
know what kind of hypnosis they put
those guys under that it works but damn
it it works and every other coach should
try to figure out how to do the same
thing with their team
i you know what mike
of all your hottest takes
i'm gonna say that i agree with that one
the most that every other coach should
try to be like bill belichick
you might have just cracked the code you
might have just cracked it but i'm
talking i'm i'm talking about i mean
think about it think about how hard that
is we talk all the time about a loss
carrying over we talk about the saints
they have two years of heartbreak that
they tried to get past the with the
patriots he has them programmed to never
think about what happened in the last
game and just move on to the next one
because mike more than anything and i've
we talked to kyle van noy last year on
pardon my take more than anything bill
belichick takes intelligent players guys
who have next level smarts knowing that
they will move on to the next thing and
learn how to evolve throughout a season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports